waiter legends of Chamberlain heights go
ahead to see our top nine lines for
smashing dawn you trying to drain these
balls from deep like Steph Curry is you
an angel cuz then beef Wang's is
smelling like what's good girl you
want to make my nine leak like Hillary
email ah you trying to get your Trump on
and hack this sack bareback for real
don't boo you trying to wet dicks and
chill you trying to attain this Django
ah say bang if I holla
you gonna swallow how about some Hulu
and chilli what the abstain calls do you
want to make this Black Mamba shoot like
Kobe ah
that's our top 9 line or smashing done
we all about to get our nuts